place which was like internal prison of
the State security this building was
known as the house of Terror to the 80
000 Georgians who had taken here during
70 years of Soviet rule up to twenty
thousand were shot mainly during Joseph
Stalin's great Terror from 1936 to 39.
once more she was arrested and shot
there guides from the Soviet past
research laboratory take tours across
Tbilisi to remind people of life in the
Soviet Union this regime had seen
propaganda worldwide propaganda that
it's a bright alternative of the West
it's a fair State it's a free state it's
a state of the lovers and The Peasants
and all this propaganda worked and also
is working today which is used by Russia
as a tool of the information war machine
but such such kind of the buildings are
illustrating the real face of the regime
recent history has helped cement many
Georgian suspicions of post-soviet
Russia Moscow has backed separatists in
the Georgian regions of abkhazia and
South asetia they fought a war with
Russia in 2008 and 280 000 Georgians
were expelled now living as Exiles in
their own country
ninety percent of Georgians according to
recent polling believe Russia poses the
greatest political threat to their
country
Russia always betrays Georgia it's in
their nature they pretend they're our
allies but in reality they're our
enemies
those views help explain why protests
buy tens of thousands of Georgians
forced the government to scrap a foreign
agent law that was viewed as being
modeled on one in Russia where it's been
used to crack down on dissent
anti-russian graffiti is everywhere in
tibilisi
the interior Ministry says 112 Russians
are here
gulab rzinkin arrived 12 months ago and
was worried about how he'd be accepted
my friends and I was a little bit
nervous coming to this process because
do you even need to be here is it our
war or is Georgian but when you're
asking locals they uh they have full
support on Russians helping them and I
think it's amazing that this stuff is
United people the Russian influx has
made Georgia one of the fastest growing
economies in the world
but opposition parties are calling for a
Visa regime for Russians echoing the
suspicions many Georgians feel towards
the new arrivals
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera tibilisi
Georgia